طيله مسار حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا منشات
مهمه واستراتيجيه كانت عرضه للاستهداف
والقصف في شرق اوكرانيا وجنوبها وايضا قرب
الشبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا وحتى
في بحر البلطيق كانت معركه ازوف ستال في
ابريل من العام الماضي حاسمه للطرفين فهي
على اراضي مصنع ازوف ستار للمعادن الذي
دمر بالكامل وهو من اكبر مصانع التعليم في
قاره اوروبا وفتحت الباب للسيطره الروسيه
على ماريوبول في صباح الثامن من اكتوبر من
العام الماضي هزا انفجار جسر القرم الذي
يربط شبه جزيره القرم بمنطقه كوبان
الواقعه في الجنوب الروسي واستخدم لتزويد
القوات الروسيه بالاسلحه خلال هجومها على
الجنوب الاوكراني واعتبرته اوكرانيا هدفا
عسكريا مشروعا محطه النوويه بدورها من
المرافق المهمه التي استهدفت اكثر من مره
في ظل اتهامات متبادله بين الطرفين بشان
قصف منشاه المحطه وسط المخاوفه من خطر
وقوع كارثه تسرب في اكبر محطه نوويه في
اوروبا خط انابيب نور ستريم او السيد
الشمالي استهدف جزء منه بتفجير في سبتمبر
من العام الماضي وهو خط انابيب مزدوج
يتجاوز طوله 2200 كيلومتر وينقل الغاز
مباشره من روسيا الى المانيا عبر بحر
البلطيق بينما نقلت واشنطن بوست عن وثائق
مسربه ان الاستخبارات الامريكيه تعتقد ان
قوات اوكرانيه خططت للهجوم سد نوفاك خفق
العملاق في خرسون جنوبيه اوكرانيا على نهر
دينيبرو منشاه اخرى عرضه للاستهداف وسط
تبادل الكلاب وموسكو الاتهامات بشان
تفجيره وتقع بجانبه محطه كخوفكال
الكهرومائيه
المتبادله بين روسيا واوكرانيا احدث
الاستهدافات تفجير جزء من خط انابيب لضخ
الامونيا بمنطقه خركيف خط التولياتي
اوديسيل ممتد لنحو 2470 كيلومترا توقف عن
العمل منذ بدا الحرب يكتسب اهميه حيويه
لتمديد اتفاق تصدير الحبوب والاسمده من
موانئ البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]